good evening
welcome to Hawthorne
the menu is a film about a high-end
restaurant run by high-end Chef who has
his own agenda I am Julian slowik and
tonight it'll be our pleasure to feed
you as each course is produced it gets a
little weirder and darker until things
get very dark indeed Margo has been
invited to the best restaurant in the
world there's a level of discomfort as
she has that keeps continuing to grow
it's official tonight will be Madness
expecting the menu of a lifetime only to
discover that there's a much bigger plan
at play please
I got really lucky with the cars we
needed to walk this specific line of
taking up Humanity very seriously
without going the other way and making
it Camp waiting in five
I love you all
slowik is you see quite a complex
character you shouldn't be here tonight
for him food is like a religion it's
quite a disturbing figure listen I said
listen
that silence means I'm free
Margo is an enigma and she's supposed to
be we're asking Anya to do so much with
very little dialogue and his ability to
switch in and out of the warmth she can
have in one moment but the hatred and
distrust and shock and that and I mean
it's just like the raw emotion Tyler
what the hell is going on Tyler is also
an obsessive but he's the exact type of
obsessive uh sluric Heats Tyler is going
to demonstrate his culinary expertise
he's fervent believer in everything Chef
slower said he worshiped him we're all
going to die at him isn't that right
Elsa is the maitre d or the restaurant
captain
's number one disciple I take care of
the customer so that Chef can take care
of the menu Hong bought tremendous depth
and a specificity to it we will not
replace me
I think Mark my Lord have created a
great atmosphere of an ensemble the
company all enjoying each other's work
and appreciating each other
it's completely different type of horror
I hope people say that they've never
seen anything like that before because I
certainly haven't
[Music]
and on that note
food
[Music]